很多等級的我剛從小韓特種冰回來
現在感覺我的臉真的就是用口啊用黃
而且我覺得我的膠原蛋白都流失了
所以今天晚上我準備做一期膠原貫服
剛好帶大家一起跟練一下
我是一定會定期做膠原貫服來抗老的
因為我的臉本身就不是屬於肉很多的那種
我和你的胖的臉變熬
而且咱們油皮只是長臟穩的速度比較慢
但是該下腸的還是會下腸
所以定期做膠原貫服真的是會感覺那臉是那種
蓬蓬亮亮的一看就是有膠原蛋白的那種
近一看皮肺也是比較細膩光滑
好廢話不多說我們馬上開始了
第一步油皮一定是打開皮普通道
我初期一點給你們看
我們油皮的毛孔
它總是這種一粒粒的
就是說我們的毛孔都是被這種油脂粒獨住的
所以這個時候你用什麼好的厚服品
都會感覺沒什麼用
因為根本進不去
所以我們先做一下毛孔的清潔
我一般就是服一個黑豆腦出驗
軟化一下我臉上的這些
油脂還有膠脂
一般就是這麼膠脂後再加一個熱棚
你就這麼真實的那種肯定
現在開始產油脂
看看就是這些東西
獨住毛孔讓呼吸品吸收不進去
好多好爽
剛剛把黑豆腦這邊洗掉了
碗臉擦乾之後再用一個酸洞磨
就塗在就種臉上了
很容易獨塞
腳這才比較厚毛孔出大的地方
這樣就可以徹底地打開我們的皮普通道
讓厚續補的膠原產品
更快更好的的皮普吃進去
擾不得一分鐘了
我現在去把臉上的酸洗掉
洗乾淨濃
水分也插乾
先噴一個噴
把臉上的這個自然水都擦掉
帶掉
然後就可以塗這個小膠原砲
就是我們家庭板膠原管服的精髓
所以所謂
你們也可以換成自己時候一頭一用的
含膠原蛋板的產品
但是一定要注意
就是要成分身比較好的
容易被我們洗手進去的
我用的這個失人
A9CO的他們家的
它叫是圖墨式的唯一美不需要
也可以直播膠原
我最開始用它是因為
我之前有一個很喜歡的法國
圓線品牌圓葉之米
他們家有一塊補膠原非常好用的圓葉廳產了
然後我就一直在找個同款
都太版蛋白成分的
我不品就找到它了
那先用一部
就按一下上的
再按一部
再次按一下
他們家的這個自體
真的是很好吸收的
就是我剛才塗那麼多
一下子就被吸收進去了
真的是跟水一樣的自體
非常的清爽
就是對我這個油皮來說
就是毫無負擔感
差點之後就是一點都不年齡
再來一部
我一共會用三棒
這個圖的臉上就是
刷刷刷的一下就被吸收了
我喜歡用它的點是
我覺得它和我之前
用過的一些補膠原的產品都不一樣
它是這種非常值得的
裡面有1.5%的A.L.B.5.32%
功能蛋白
這個成分就是從
多木臺盤當中提取的
市面上的灰味
大部分
他們都是從植物當中提取的
但其實多木提取出來的
才是比較接近我們皮膚的
才會更容易被我們皮膚吃進
他們家用的是
市面上最小分子的蕭圓
像我們皮膚需要的
一型三型合適七型蕭
裡面都有直接幫我們補充蕭圓
同時還可以讓我們皮膚理由的
自行身長
就用了它之後
我才相信
原來豐富品
它是真的可以做到蕭圓值不得
所以用它來在家裡面做蕭圓
觀服像我真的很好
不僅是即使蕭
果像我日常早晚我也是用它
臉那種
蓬蓬亮亮的
睡飽蕭的好狀態
可以維持很久
而且它做成這種雙層涉及
就可以盡可能的保鮮裡面的活性成分
用錢就把它按下去搖匀就可以了
它們一小隻基本上是七天可以用完
但是如果我用它做
貫服的話一次
就差不多可以用半瓶
現在我們三層已經吸收完了
然後我會在後面膚裡騙生物鮮尾面膜
我們看一下什麼是生物鮮尾面膜
這種生物鮮尾的面膜
它的精華業基本上都在它的面膜裡面
這個面膜的精華業
它就不會很吸很水
就不會吸事掉
我們前面上的那三層交圓胖
單比的姐妹可以上完交圓胖之後
再用一個精華有去做一個面膜
再服裏片這種生物鮮尾膜
因為精油的分子量更小
它會更有利於我們前面塗的交圓產品的吸收
但這個加精華有的步驟
我就會放在秋冬天在族
因為現在我的臉還沒有那麼乾
我們服務15分鐘
封面膜這部就是為了加壓促勝
把前面膜的交圓精華都對進去
好了15分鐘了
現在面膜的精華業基本都會被吸收掉了
這個精華業如果是
你們覺得可以吸收的話那就不行
就直接就這樣子了
繞一樓按摩就可以了
但是我一般會用一個
大師的這個棉片
把臉上這個沒有吸收完的
面膜精華業稍微的插掉一點
現在就感覺
皮膚特別的這種軟弱
特別軟弱
再來一部交圓胖
我們給它加新鮮乾脂的封層
這是我上了這四邊
夏天的話我就喜歡這種無複帶的怪不方式
能感覺到我開始塗了那麼多的精華嗎
真的全部都被吸收進去
最後再加一個KL的面膜進行封層
塗出之前的營養和水分
就可以了
做完這一套
你真的會馬上就感覺皮膚變得非常的水嫩
而且是很有光澤的
按壓起來是很有彈性的
真的可以讓我們皮背的肌膚狀態也回春
然後給你看一下
因為我真的特別喜歡用這個交圓胖
所以IWG我把他們加新出的這個刺胖一買了
我剛設了一下膚蓋也可以
等我再用久一點
如果好用我覺得你的分享